складаю про порядок денний прем'єр-міністра
практично він одразу після покращення
арсенієм яценюком про свій вид ставку
юму зате love сумував і 2 на еблище
партнери України
канцлер до них і чон це віце-президент
США Ангела Меркель то Джозеф Байден
поляку вала українському прем'єру за
роботу то запам'ятав ще захід і чи треба
Петро йому в цьому та українці знайшли хори
форм і євроінтеграції віце-президента
дякова прем'єр міністру яценюку за
партнерство проти історичного розуму
періоду для України
win pro with a foul від україни з дощок
наймай в астані сир і
засіки праворуч даним складних alive
вкрай орхідних економічних реформ
приписом води просто зробити з е100
прогресом та зближення енергетичну на
за важливості разом steam європейський
політик іншого коня зміїне кіза
початку вау ряд яценюка мати бутан
виворот нами призначений аж вище ми ж
ставка та туніка вигляд крила шлях
українським політикам до формування
ефективного уряду та c чоловіка but i про
станемо шансом для України
довести свою потужність до змін
особливо його тпр моєї при скоро ти себе
процесора формування наук видно єгипет
ринку люди світу форм а також для мої
будні на демократії та про європейського
розвитку України
коаліція мої збори туго ти себе прийду
боротьбі проти корупції це за
верховенству права
головне а вільне крісло прем'єра на
столом стартом для нових політичних
чувак на томі шви смак формуватися нові
diy знатне уряд борги знання українців
політиків за іклів міністр закордонних
праворуч литви лінас лінкявічюс показати
ще український ур відхідливий.
реформ і робити їх за ікло la
європарламент арка ребекка хармс за
галон захід позитивної ціни для
касіана не арсенія яценюка так його вигляд
ставку а dc барелла україну виду
рядкових виборі фалуджі вид затяжний
політичного щура